hi everyone welcome to our daily
homeroom I'm very excited about the
guests we have today and before we we
jump into that conversation I will give
my standard announcement remind everyone
that Khan Academy is a not-for-profit
organization that we can only exist with
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please think about donating to
Khan Academy I want to give a special
shout out to several corporations who
have helped support us especially when
they found out that we're running at a
deficit preak ovid and then because of
kovat our server costs have gone up
we've been trying to accelerate a whole
series of programs so special thanks to
Bank of America google.org 18t fastly
and Novartis so with that I'm really
excited to introduce our next guest
James Monica I have many connections and
there's many reasons why James is
interesting I consider him a friend a
mentor he is also a board member of Khan
Academy and his day job is he is the
head of the McKinsey Global Institute so
James thanks for joining us may be a
good place to start is for those who
don't know McKinsey or the McKinsey
Global Institute what what is that well
thank you some so delighted to to be
here and for those situations where I
feel like you're one of my teachers you
know it's kind of like when you teach
invite you to class you're kind of
terrified because they've been your
teacher so I'm kind of a little
terrified right now but I'm delighted to
to be here
the answers been so humble he knows with
your elementary builds in this
relationship
no no but so thank you for having me so
the McKinsey Global initiatives kind of
Mackenzie's economics and research
think-tank if you like so we research
trends in the economy the impact the
technology is having on society we look
at issues around economic growth
inequality globalization so these are
trends we spend a lot of time thinking
about and we try and make our views kind
of benefit leaders with us leaders in in
the private sector in business and
nonprofits in government many of those
folks around the world take advantage of
the research that we do
so what I'm hoping to talk to James
about I think there's there's many
things we could talk to him about but
directly rated to his work and he
obviously sits on the board of Khan
Academy and several other foundations I
you know I'd love to dive into you know
even pre covet James has done a lot of
interesting work around the future of
work and what will technology and
automation do to it there's then a layer
that kovat has added to it then there's
a layer of you know the environment
we're in around the anti recent racism
movement how do we increase diversity
equity and inclusion in corporations and
then you know what things might
transcend beyond the covetous or beyond
the news cycle that we happen to be in
so if anyone has any questions on
YouTube or Facebook please put your
questions in the message boards we have
team members who are looking at them and
they'll surface those questions to
myself and James but with James just to
get everyone grounded you know given the
work that you just described that the
McKinsey Global Institute does you know
what even pre kovat what trends have you
seen or are you all prognosticating
about the future of work you know what
is automation going to do what is
globalization or D globalization going
to do well I think you know work has
been changing and will continue to
change in some profound ways and I think
there are a few different things that
are driving those changes the first one
is the role of technology and automation
we know that this is disparate this is a
trend that's been going on for for
centuries actually every time we've
invented new ways of technological ways
to compliment where people do the work
that people do there's always been this
ongoing kind of tension and coevolution
between what people do and what the
machines around them to do so the role
of technology and automation is one of
those trends that affects work the other
trend has been affecting work is the
fact that there are now many more
varieties of work so we know that there
are people who do full-time jobs there
are people who not do independent work
the gig economy so the set of
arrangements that we put around work of
kind of expanded some of that has been
driven by the fact that some of these
alternative models are flexible for
people useful for people a lot of people
to come
their incomes when they're not earning
enough in their full-time jobs so this
variety of work phenomena has also been
changing our work quite a bit so we you
know these are trends Sal that were
already underway
even before covered that already
impacted sectors like manufacturing so
if you had gone to a factory in 1980
versus a factory in 2018 it looked very
different you probably wouldn't see as
many people there you've probably seen a
lot of robots and machines assembling
things on the assembly line so this was
already changing but I think one of the
things that as we look forward that's
become important is that with the
emergence and progress in artificial
intelligence for example we're starting
to see machines that are capable of
doing some of those things that we often
associated with human intelligence the
ability to understand patterns the
ability to think through some kinds of
classes of problems and so that the
expansion and emergence of artificial
intelligence has made many people start
to worry about
so therefore what do people do in the
future so that's been one of the trends
we've been looking at along with the
varieties of work I should point out
though sorry you're about to ask
something no no keep going I was gonna
ask you know all the things you alluded
to automation artificial intelligence
you know there's people who can paint a
very dystopian future that most jobs
could get taken away I mean people talk
about self-driving cars and trucks and
even a lot of office work or even a rate
you know AIS that can do you know deep
learning algorithms that are better at
diagnosing radiate radiological images
better than radiologists do you all see
a future where we have this mass
displacement of you know tens of
millions of people even in just the US
or do you think it's more gradual and we
shouldn't be so scared well we shouldn't
be so scared because one of the things
that actually happens is that and I'll
illustrate this with the story so you
know you're a student of history cell
and you know so in
I may not know this but in in the 60s
President Lyndon Johnson put together a
commission which is a Blue Ribbon
Commission to look at the future of work
and the role of automation while the
conclusions in the report in 1967 were
Sanders always struck stuck with me and
what that what that conclusion was that
technology destroys jobs but not work
that is actually quite important because
what happens as we've seen both
historically but also looking forward is
that yes there will be some occupations
that will decline you know we don't have
people driving horse and buggies anymore
we don't have people who operate
elevators anymore except maybe in a few
remaining places so some jobs will
decline but many more actually grow and
emerge because there's still work that
needs to be done so when you look at the
puts and takes if you like much of the
research we've done and in fact many
other economists have done and
technologists have done and east of the
night looking at the next few decades
and this suggests that yes while some
jobs will be lost there will also be
jobs gained meaning jobs that will grow
and emerge as a result of new things
that we'll do in the economy so I like
to think of this as what we see with
technology and automation is a phenomena
of three kinds actually yes some jobs
lost some jobs gained but also many more
jobs changed and the jobs changed part
is quite important think about you know
whatever you know the things you spend
your day doing Sal you know most
occupations consist of 20 different 20
30 different constituent activities some
of those are being replaced by others
concision activities have been replaced
by technology your job is still there
you mentioned the radiologists if you
look at what the radiologists actually
does the amount of time that they spent
looking at images is I think the number
in the u.s. is something like 38 percent
is the time to actually spend looking at
images there are other things that they
do they
are coordinating things that doing
research they do a whole bunch of other
things so that's an example where a
portion of their work changes think
about the bank teller which is a faster
example if you had looked at a bank
teller in 1970 what did they spend the
majority of their time doing counting
your money either to take it from you
when you give it to them or to give it
back to you when you ask for it that was
like 80% of their time then the ATM
showed up well you don't need them to do
that do we still have been tell us we do
what do they do quite different
activities so if you look at the amount
of time bank tellers are spending
counting money
it's a tiny portion the rest of the time
they're doing customer service they're
helping you think about you know
accounts you wanna open a whole bunch of
things that's an example of a job that's
changed because of the advent of
technology so we'll see this phenomenon
of jobs lost jobs gained in jobs changed
is an important thing to keep in mind as
you think about the impact of technology
on our society and what do you think
well you know there's a bunch of
questions and even a few that I'm seeing
from from YouTube you know just do a
synopsis of some of these is I think
everyone I hear you but you know there's
a general feeling that artificial
intelligence might be different than
just the traditional forms of automation
that have happened before and that even
if it doesn't net kill work does it
change the equality or inequality and
this kind of starts going into what
we're seeing with Co vid what we're
seeing with a lot of the issues you know
that kovat might have only highlighted
around inequality whether it's around
income around race is should we be
afraid and it's kind of a lot of the
tension we're feeling almost a byproduct
of some of these trends starting to
really hit home I think the question is
is an important one to think about
because you know well as I said before I
worried less about other is they're
gonna be working the future because I
think there will be net of the things I
just described but there is something I
worry about these are a couple things
you worry about I do worry about impact
on incomes and wages because I'll give
our illustrate this as an example sell
many of the hardest automate occupations
tend to be you know so think about care
work for example it's very very hard to
fully automate that think about some of
the hardest many of those occupations
have tended to be occupations that the
wages have not been great for actually
so there's a worried that even if we
have enough work it's possible that many
of the jobs won't paid very well and
that's that's something I do worry about
and it that would actually exacerbate
the challenges we already have with with
inequality it's something that people
have worried about for a long time you
often hear politicians say you know we
need good jobs back when you factory
jobs are good jobs it is true
manufacturing jobs have historically
paid quite well but that's also where
we've seen a lot of automation where as
many of the jobs that have grown in the
service sector have tended to be not all
of them but many of them have tended to
be jobs that don't pay as well so yes
the the income inequality course is
clearly one that we should worry about
the other one we should worry about are
be skills and adaptation that people are
gonna have to go through so even if
there is enough work you know and people
work alongside the machines that's gonna
require slightly different skills
slightly different mix of skills so how
do we retrain everybody how do we keep
people skills adaptable as they end up
working alongside technology so these
issues of skills and adaptation and the
income questions are things that do
worry me and I worry less about what
will there be jobs or worry more about
will they be the right kind of jobs and
I'll be tackle inequality now many of
these issues you know we've often talked
about themselves the future of work when
some ways kovat is kind of accelerated
all of that and it's now kind of here
and maybe that's something we should
talk about it what
seeing around work in this moment right
I mean you know from Facebook we have
this question from Matthew Kavanagh is a
I'm making it impossible to predict the
work a future of work and work patterns
several people have kind of alluded to
what should they do with their life I'm
assuming they're they're high school or
college students and you're absolutely
right Co vyd has you know there's kind
of these two worlds people like me and
you who can for the most part continue
to do our work from our home offices and
then a lot of people in service
industries and wherever else where they
they can't and it's made inequality
maybe worse so what advice would you
give and what trends do you think from
kovat are are real and that we really do
have to struggle with well I think it's
important before we get to what we do
about it to actually fully understand
what what's been exposed with regards to
work and inequality by this corporate
moment so right now for example if you
look at the US workforce something like
about a third worker that I would call
vulnerable and let me describe what I
mean by vulnerability these are workers
are vulnerable to layoffs or to being
furloughed or experiencing reduced hours
and income as a result of body the
public safety concerns about health or
the fact that their sector that they
work in has essentially shut down sort
of example if you happen to work in
their restaurant for example or in the
travel industry what there isn't a whole
lot going on right now so a third of the
US workforce that's vulnerable in that
said that's a very large number now if
you look at the profile of who those
workers are it's something like 80% of
them are low wage workers meaning that
they earn less than $40,000 a year so
it's disproportionately impacting
low-income workers the most a large
portion of them don't have college
degrees or college education 80% of them
actually and many of them are
disproportionately people of color black
and brown people so you know if there
was already
inequality in in
educational sense or in an or wage sense
or in a demographic sense we're seeing
it in full-blown force and and those are
people as you said sell many of those
occupations you can't do them remotely
in the way you and I can do what we do
because we know that something like
almost 45% of those vulnerable workers
their work has to be done in some
physical place somewhere you can't do it
over zoom or whatever technology you
happen to be using so that's a real
concern so the question is what do we do
about that I think lots of things first
was to solve for the public health
concerns because a lot of the people who
are most exposed in the public health
sense have tended to be many of those
same workers we also have to so have to
solve for their health safety give them
the right equipment PPE and so forth and
making sure that they've got they're
protected if they have to go out to do
work there but the other thing is to
think about how do we supplement their
incomes and help them and support them
so some of the stimulus checks or the
unemployment insurance checks have
helped a lot but one of the things we
realizing is that because we have a
system where a lot of the access to
health services or benefits are tied to
employers well if employers shut things
down we've essentially potentially cut
off people from some of the health and
other benefits that they might have got
so that's exposing the the difficulty
where we've got a benefit system that's
inherently tied to employment so these
are some of the things we have to tackle
if we're going to support those exposed
and vulnerable workers and do you think
there's some limit to I mean this goes
into more from the macro economics
question that I've asked other guests
but you know trillion here trillion
there starts to add up at some point
what do you think is the limit at which
you know the government won't be able to
you know write checks to hold people
over essentially well this is the
constant difficulty of balancing the
short term in the long term so you know
in the short term sense I
say let's help people as much as we can
because that's the challenge that's here
and now those are workers we need to
support an economy needs support to are
exposed in the public health sense right
now and also in a in an economic sense
right now so we have to protect their
lives and livelihoods this is something
we've been writing a lot about how do we
protect lives and livelihoods in this
moment but but it also then
has this other long-term consequence
which is because they don't the way the
economic system gets to write those
checks or trillion here trillion there
is that in some ways we're borrowing
from the future if you like in a way so
this is the tough combination but
personally I would say you know let's
tackle the issues that are right in
front of us right now which is people
who are exposed whose lives are exposed
and whose livelihoods are exposed so
anything we can do to help them I think
is fundamentally important right right
and what I've you know the general sense
I've been hearing and even when I think
about myself is the Fed is aggressive
that helps lower interest rates they're
essentially printing money and then the
government can borrow it you know record
low interest rates and really the risk
in the short to medium term is inflation
which doesn't seem if anything deflation
because of all the other trends you
talked about like automation it might be
a bigger risk oh it would be so so in
fact the the one of the other challenges
we're facing by the way as I mentioned
there's a lot of workers were exposed
where I died they're vulnerable because
they can't they can't work and so forth
well we know ready that you know
something like 40% of those occupations
also our occupations that are at risk of
automation so so you know the interplay
of these dynamics is is really really
important but I think one of the things
many of us are concluding is that we
can't have two civil tennis lee solve
these two things which is how do we
solve deal with the public health crisis
that we've got at the same time we're
finding safe ways to keep the economy
and reopen the economy and those two
things kind of go hand to hand I think
Challenge we've got practically is that
you know we're running a you know fifty
experiments if you like in fact more
than that in the sense that every state
is kind of doing their own thing right
it's more than that because even within
states you find some cities some
counties are doing things a little bit
differently that actually makes it very
complicated and in fact raises the
potential that we're gonna be kind of in
this bumpy road for a while and recovery
will probably take even longer because
we kind of waited on the one end for the
public health crisis to abate or be
under control and you're waiting for
vaccines and you had bill gates talking
about that we wait there appease but
also we need to safe ways to reopen and
we're trying to reopen and get the
economy so I worried that we're going to
be in this mode of kind of you know you
know small steps bumpy steps back and
forth and forward hopefully for quite a
while for longer than we would like and
that that's a warrant and then related
to this and I do think it is somewhat
related I don't think it's a coincidence
that we're seeing the kind of mass
protests in in you know what when you
already had this you know covet
happening in the background but you have
you've had obviously the murder of
George George Floyd which has kind of
reinvigorated or really opened up
conversations around systemic racism
police brutality I'm curious your point
of view obviously personally how it
affects you and your family and and but
also as someone who thinks
systematically about business and jobs
you know there's a fear that a lot of
companies you know are you know they do
lip service to the notions of diversity
and inclusivity but at the end of the
day behind closed doors will say well
but it's a harder problem there's you
know they'll talk about the pipeline
problem but you know it starts maybe its
Khan Academy's problem because we have
to start with students when they're in
pre-k in elementary school and and all
that how do you think about I mean how
is it how are you think about it
personally what do you think has to
change so that it
we don't keep repeating this and and how
do you think the the role of the
business community should they be taking
to not just do lip service well these
are really big questions silence you
know but you asked about the personal my
own personal
and I've lived in the United States now
for about 20 years and I can tell you
these issues affect me and affect
everyone one of the things that's been
surprising to me is the you know even
when people understand things is the
presumption that oh it happens to those
people over there you know poor
disadvantaged people of color but I
think it happens to all people of color
so let me give you some personal
experience it doesn't matter you know
you know I mean I'm fairly privileged
lucky to do the things that I do and so
forth but that doesn't stop the police
stopping me occasionally which happens
it doesn't stop you know showing up you
know I work in Silicon Valley showing up
at a at a company to say I'm here to me
to the CEO and I'm told oh you can leave
it here right the presumption being
there to deliver something right so so
it happens to all of us there isn't a a
black male in this country who apart
from people perhaps who are recognisably
celebrities there's the black male I
know
CEO down to the janitor who hasn't got a
story to tell you about some experience
that they've had in a store somewhere so
this happens to all of us and we're
constantly thinking about that I worry
about I'm the father of a young black
you know black man I worry about it when
he goes out so these are very personal
issues but I think zooming out from the
personal
I think perhaps what we're seeing is you
know these have been issues that have
been there for a very long time and you
know it's a combination I think perhaps
this moment was a bit of a boiling over
point with the death of George Floyd
that kind of brought things to a for but
these issues of inequity sister systemic
inequities both in the not just in the
police in criminal justice system but in
society economically have persisted for
a very long time and I think you know
what I'm hopeful is that maybe this time
things will be different
and people start to take you know
address them directly I've been quite
encouraged we'll see but I've been
encouraged by the fact that there's been
a bit of a collective
chorus of recognition of these issues
not Universal of course but at least you
know a larger chorus than before and I
see it both in the inside large
companies in the private sector in
foundations and unsocial in the in the
social sector so that chorus I think is
encouraging I'm also seeing it go beyond
just a chorus but people starting to
propose actions that they're gonna take
the hardest there's some easy actions
important but easy actions the easy
actions I think for companies is to
write a check so I donate to this cause
and that cause in front this from that
that's great it's happening and I think
many will benefit that way the harder
thing is to actually change
organizations change for example
leadership change attitudes towards
these issues change hiring practices
address some of the biased questions
that affect candidates when they're
applying for jobs in work those are much
harder things to to do and but I think
people are committing to doing those so
I'm hopeful I'm optimistic in that sense
and just even from your vantage point is
you know one of the senior leaders at
McKinsey which is you know for those who
don't know McKinsey it is kind of you
know considered kind of the elite of the
elite in terms of strategy consulting
firms and you know y'all are the
advisors to CEOs and governments around
the world
so a lot of ways you'll have influence
with a lot of other entities and then
also what y'all obviously do with your
own organization do you see that there
there will be change are you and what
are those levers like you know if you
have to pick your top three levers on
any of these issues obviously there's
the police brutality issue which you
know we might have limited control over
that's kind of a sheriff government
police union type issue but in the
corporate sector what levers would you
well I think in the corporate sector
it's committing to the kind of
inclusivity that we're talking about I
mean you know for those who are
interested even we at McKinsey actually
put out ten actions that we're going to
take and some of the harder ones in the
private sector for many of us is to make
sure
we recruit differently rehired
differently we address issues of bias
and how people progress we make sure
people are being mentored and and have
allies I mean this is one of those
things Sal where you you know the the
the people of color can't just you know
work on this by themselves I think
there's a sense of a need for collective
ownership of the fact that we do want to
hire differently we do want to look at
candidates across the board we do want
to look at people's skills we do want to
look at you know how do we support
people progress those are some of the
more kind of cultural things to think
about I think there's there's some
wonderful work and research that was
done by Claude Steele so Claude was the
Provost at Berkeley and Columbia before
that is a professor at Stanford about
these issue of stereotyping and bias in
how we coach each other support each
other I mean you you know you're a
teacher you're educating people but even
the way a learner and the teacher or you
know it's a worker and working there
supervisor who's coaching and mentoring
them paying attention to these things
makes enormous difference it makes
enormous difference so many corporations
are we're doing it ourselves going
through training about systemic bias how
do you watch for that how do you make
sure in the coaching and mentoring
you're not inadvertently kind of biasing
the feedback and the learning that's the
hard work that we were all gonna have to
do and we have McKinsey I know you know
have as much work to do as anybody we
don't have enough black leaders at
McKinsey we don't have enough people of
color and you know coming through in the
organization we're all working hard at
it so we've made a commitment to double
for example leadership in our firm at
all levels in the next you know in four
years or less that's that's gonna be
hard for us you know that's big but
we're making yeah and you know that
going back to I mean there's a ton of
questions are coming in and these
conversations always go faster than I
expect cuz there's so much to talk about
I mean you know there's a couple of
questions people are asking I mean going
back to the work question about you know
what should people do with their lives
given the uncertainty
there's there's questions about what do
you think are going to be the permanent
effects of kovat but I would even
extended kovat and and a lot of what we
just talked about there's a very
particular question about from Facebook
about what do you think about the
Trump's h-1b policy the visa policy you
know I'd like to you know take it where
you'd like to take it James in the few
minutes we have left
yeah so it's worth talking perhaps about
what's gonna be permanent post coporate
maybe as trends that people can
anticipate as people think about what to
do how we adapt and just I think we've
seen ourselves go through some rapid
global experiments I was referring to
the work from home we've experimented
from remote learning and people have you
know more people that are already using
Khan Academy of discovered Khan Academy
thankfully you know in this moment and
that's a wonderful thing but I think
many of those things aren't gonna change
I think we've seen the benefits of some
of those things we've seen the value
some people have from working from home
the flexibility but some people want to
go back to work
so the workplace itself I think is going
to look quite different the learning
environment I think is going to look
quite different I think we've learned
that you know we may be in a no-contact
or at least a low contact economy I
think some of the experiences are social
distancing and avoiding density I'm not
sure all of those will go away I think
we've seen growth in telehealth for
example people be more comfortable doing
health consultations remotely I think
much of that is going to stay so those
are things that I think are going to be
with us for awhile to the question of
you know what you know how can one adapt
and learn I think you know it's one
things I love what Khan Academy I think
they're being in a mode where we are
perpetually learning and augmenting our
skills of what we know I think that's
just be it's just going to become a
lifelong skill learning to learn and
learning to that permanently and
perpetually is one thing the other thing
I would also add is we're going to see
the importance of both skills
not just the stem skills but also even
some of the artistic skills I think it's
gonna be the combination of these other
social skills with some what piece of
you have called steam right by adding a
to stem aid for the arts I think that
combination is going to be quite
important and those who have both kinds
of combinations of skills I think are
going to do well so those were the two
things that emphasize learning
constantly learning and having this
duality between stem and artistic and
social skills I think it's going to be
quite important yeah and I always find
steam entertaining because it really
just means being a well-rounded human
being it's covering everything exactly
exactly exactly
well James unfortunately we're all out
of time you know considering you're a
board member I consider it your duty to
do this again so I hope we can have more
of these conversations I think we just
start scratching the surface on a lot of
this especially even the future of work
etc etc so thank you James so much for
joining and I and I hope we do to get to
do this in another couple of weeks well
thank you for having me and you know
welcome support from those watching Khan
Academy it's a wonderful wonderful
resource so thank you thanks James so
thanks everyone for joining as you can
see just another fascinating
conversation James is a big hero of mine
and someone I definitely look up to and
is a great board member for Khan Academy
and I look forward to not only bringing
him on in the future but we have many
other really interesting guests coming
up and I will see you at future live
streams see y'all later
you